では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは基本的にまずあの
まあ省略のところを説明いたしますけど
まあ我々の人生っていうのはね
まあいろんなことに出会わなくちゃいけない
かなり心が激しく動揺したりする
それでそれに耐えられなくなってね
まあ大変なことになったりもする
まあよくあることは このまあ現代
この先進国々では この精神的な問題っていうのは
まあ風邪引くよりは当たり前になってます
まあ風邪引く...ちょっと前に出してください
前に出してください スピーカーそのまま近すぎ
はい そこら辺 まあどこでもいいんですけど
一緒ではあまり相性が悪いんです
えーと まあ風邪引く人々の数が少ないんですよ
まあ別にね まあ先進国々っていうのは
この清潔であることにとても気をつけますからね
だから環境もきれいでしょうし
食べるものもきれいでしょうし
まあ風邪引くということはあまりないんですけど
その代わりに精神的な問題っていうのは
まあほとんど ないという人はいないぐらい
まあもう時々もう嫌になるほど
それってどういうことでしょうかっていうと
やっぱりこのいろんなもうことが毎日起きてるこの世界でね
我々生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから心動揺せずいることっていうのは難しいんです
それから 例えば日本の社会を見ても
すごく巨大な社会なんですよ
東京っていうのは世界でね
大きな街のもう都会の一つでしょうね
何番目かわかりませんだけど
では 東京という大都会に住んでるんだからといって
我々何人と知り合ってますかね
はっきり言おうと ものすごい田舎で交通便もない
33時間に1本ぐらいバスは行かないぐらいのところに住んでいる人々は
みんな互い知ってます
自分が生きる環境 縄張りがすごい大きいんです
東京で住んでる人々の縄張りは
両手ちょっと伸ばしちゃうと
まあそんな程度ですよ
もう壁にぶつかりますからね
他の人のこと知らないんですよ
どこか事件が起きちゃうと
テレビ局の人々はマイクロフォンを持っていろんな人のところに行くでしょ
あの人はどういう人 どんな人でしょうかとか
で テレビ局でスクリプト書いてくれないと
何人か何者かと言えないんです
知らないんだから 別に事件が起きても隣知らないんですよ
で 昔私は渋谷で留学生会館にいた時は
ある女性が自殺しちゃったんです
学生が で 知らなかったんです
で 我々は留学生同士でね
結構みんなと仲良くいろいろ喋ったりしますけども
女子寮は後ろにあったんだから
私は全然そちらに行かないし
ミャンマーの人でしたけどね
で 話したりする場合はもうなんとかしてあげることできたんですけど
まあヨーロッパの人々はよく喋ったり友達になったりするんですけども
アジアの人々はまあどうも隠れますからね
とにかく何かある日 なんか車何台か特別に車何台かあるんです
見たら一つ二つぐらい警察との名前もあって
他は全然もう何も書いてない普通の車
それは誰もなんでこんなたくさん今日車が来ているのかって聞いたら
その時知ったんです  それでも誰かとわからない
行った人もあまりわからない
すごい苦労して 誰でしょうかと
どんな部屋のいた人でしょうか
調べたところでやっとわかったんであって
だから留学生で みんなお互い兄弟同士でもうわいわいと喋りながら喧嘩しながらずっと生きているのに
そういうことで そんな仲良くはしません
普通の社会では というわけで
我々はこの現代社会で
この発展しているこの社会で生きている場合は
ものすごく信じられないほど狭い環境で生きているんです
これってとっても人間にとっては良くないんです
なぜならば まあいろんな人と話したり関係を持ったりすると
かなり自分の精神が弱くなる
強くなるんです 一人一人がいろいろ自分の性格は持っていて
生き方を持っていて だからそこら辺はよく理解して生活しなくちゃいけない
そういうことで 私たちは生きている世界はすごい狭いし
5 6人  7 8人しか知らないし
年賀状はたくさん出すんですけど
誰とも付き合いはないでしょうに
それからもう社会の激しい変動に対応しなくちゃいけないし
なかなかできるものではないんです
新しく店を開いても たくさん友達が知っているならば
みんなに話しかけてこちらに来てよと
もう今日から他のところで買い物するんじゃないよと
私は店を始めたんだからという風に言えば
その始めた日からもういくらか店が動いてますよ
そうすると気楽にどんどん他の客も来るようになってきて
店はもう発展するんですけど
東京で店を一つ開いても
全く一人で 2 3人でやって
店を開いて もう空を見て待たなくちゃいけないんですね
客が来るか来ないかと
旅行のそういう関係ない
だから店を開く人というのはすごく不安を持ってますよ
たくさんのお金をね もう投資しているし
どうなるでしょうか ものすごい不安を持ってるんです
そうするともう 1週間
2週間  1ヶ月間ぐらい
もうそれほど誰も来なかったならば
もうなおさらもう 大変不安になるんです
雇っている人に給料を払わなくちゃいけないし
また家賃やらいろいろもうお金行くばっかりで
どうしようかと そういうわけで
もうもう信じられないほど
我々は精神的な拷問を受けて生きていなくちゃいけないんです
だから先進国で生まれてよかったというふうに一概には言えませんよ
冷蔵庫やらテレビやらあるんだからと
もう家に絨毯は敷いているとか
私たちの場合は絨毯の
まあ土間の場合もありますけどね
そこでゴザを敷いて寝たりしますけど
しかし そういうあまり文明の壁がない場合は
人間お互いに話し合ったりする
そこで精神的に悩んだり困ったりということはないんです
子供の問題 よくあるでしょうに
信じられない なんで子供は親に口聞きするのかと
それはどう考えたってもありえない話なんです
動物さえも親に対してはものすごく親切ですから
親と子の同士で何でもできるでしょうに
母親が何言ったっても
どんな侮辱したっても
子供全然普通だったら気にもしない
母親が殴ったっても 痛いじゃないかと言って
それで終わっちゃうんです
この怒ったり喧嘩したり
母親父親を殴ったりとか
これはもう哺乳類の中でありえない話ですよ
日本で毎日のようにある
だから心は完全にイカれていますよ
もうどうしようもない
母を知らない心はイカれているじゃなくて
どうなってますかね 人間は人間ですけど
母親父親っていうのは特別な存在ですよ
子供にしてみれば だからそういうものすごい悲しいというか
理解もしにくい もう対策方法もないという
だからもう完全にイかれている場合は
どこから治療すればいいんですかね
治療っていうのは修復だから
ちょこちょこっと壊れたら手当てをして修復する
体の病気の場合でも 心の病気の場合でも
治療っていうのは修復なんです
レペアリングなんです
英語で言えば 全部こんなことに壊れたら
もう修復も何でも不可能ですでしょうに
家の窓ガラス一つ割れたらどうったことない
これは修復できます 天井のシーツが 2つ
3つぐらい落ちちゃったと
大丈夫です 修復できます
何か隕石でも落ちて もう屋根に穴が開けたと
そんなこと丸ことない
もう修復できます しかし
家丸ごとにつぶれたらどうしますかね
修復の話じゃないでしょ
そういうことで 我々の心っていうのは
そこまで壊れているという
悲しいんですよ 私は悲しいっていうのはあまりあてにならない言葉で
私は腹が立ってるんです
なんでこうするのかと
なんでこうなるのかと
そこで問題っていうのは
この私たちの生きる環境がすごい狭すぎて免疫がない
人間の心を理解できない
人間 世の中でものすごいたくさんいるんだということは知らない
一人一人が別な思考で別な生き方を持ってるんだとも知らない
それから仲良くする方法も知らない
その上で社会はもう毎日毎日変わっていくんです
自分が服のデザインをもう毎月ごとに変えなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 友達と仲良く たくさんの人々と話し合って
こうしましょうという話はできません
ただ 冊子を見ながら カタログを見ながら
自分一人だけでそこで自分がかっこいいと思っている服を着て外へ出たっても
誰一人も知らないけれども
なかなかかっこいいんじゃと言えますでしょうね
それはないんです 友達がいないんだから
だから結構虚しいんですよ
男性にしたっても すごい高価なネクタイつけて電車に乗って誰も見ようともしないんです
そういうことで 結局は精神的には息苦しいということがあります
ちょっとしたことに対応できない
子供はもう自分が育てる子供なんですけど
思春期になってくるとお手上げ
どうにもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜかというと経験がないんです
自分の子供しか見たことがない
だからどうやって対応すればいいかわからない
なんで親に向かってかかってくるのかわからない
それでそれなりに興奮しちゃって
怒ってあれこれするとますますまずい状態になるんです
いくらか横の人間関係あったならば
そんなのは何のこともない
どんな反応すればいいかとわかります
その場合は だから一番親が助けてあげなくちゃいけない時っていうのは思春期なんですよ
その時に限って親がまるっきり無能
だからもうなかなか人格は成長しないってことになっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから この我々はこの世の中でどのように生きるべきかというね
それは学ぶ必要がありますけど
仏教はああいう こんな風に基本喋りますけど
やっぱりたくさん横の慈しみを持った人々と
たくさんの人々と仲良くすることっていうのは
これは欠かせないことなんです
その能力は必要なんです
だから今日はもう言うわけで
できるだけ具体的な話を捨てちゃって
まあ論理的なところだけ言っちゃおうかなと
前はもう論理的な話を喋ったってもね
あまり理解もできないし
まあちょこちょこと具体的な物語ぐらい喋った方がいいんじゃないかなと思っていたんですけど
まだ今回も一応理論だけにはなります
でも理論だけでは生きていられません
それはよく覚えてほしいんです
慈しみはああだこうだとか
頭がんじがらめでいくら学んだっても
隣の人とどんな風に慈しみを実践すればという実践的なこととこがないと
嫌なことを言っている人に対しても
一人二人だけでもいいんですよ
すごく嫌なことを言ったりしたりというのはね
自分がそれでもニコニコとその人のことをすごく心配して
思いやりを持って対応すると
それで経験がついてきますよ
だから仏教といえば日本
勉強しようと思ったら
皆様もういくらでも誰にでもできるし
もう大学でもあるしあるんですよね
いくらでも勉強できますよ
なんで私の話がもう世界一流の知識人たちの仏教の研究論文やらね
話やらすごい差があるんですかね
頭だけで観念でガチャガチャ本をページめくったりして
このページでこうあります
あの本で 3 ページにこうありますとか並べてるだけです
何でも味わったことはない
実践したことはない 実行したことはない
だから水泳に対して 運転に対して結構本読んでいるんだっていうことなんです
しかし 水に入ったことはないし
車のステアリングホイールは触ったことはありませんと
さしえだったらいくらでも見たことがあるんだよと
何の意味もありませんよ
そういうことだから この我々はとにかくこのとにかく実行してみるという
たとえわずかでも たとえ一人二人
二人相手であっても 慈しみを実行してみる
そういう風にやってみないと役には立ちません
それから 苦しいことやら楽しいことやらね
いろんなことが出来上がる
現れるたびに 我々は激しく動揺して
もともと心は弱いです
その上激しい竜巻起きちゃうと
もうあたふたもなく壊れますよ
だからどうすればいいかと
で まあ今日はパーリ お釈迦様の言葉は引用しないんです
まあ引用しようと思っても
あんまりたくさんなりすぎちゃってね
まあどちらを選ぼうかということも
ちょっとあんまりはっきりしないしね
で ほとんど皆様の方々は覚えている
今日 宝経の ほとんど協会の方々は覚えているでしょ
えーと 何番目でしたっけ
まあ 8番目の経と思いますけど
ヤディンダキーローパタウィンストーシア
チャトゥッビワーテービアサンパカンピヨー
タトゥーパマンサップリサンワダーミヨーアリーアサッチャーニアウィッチャパッサティという経があるんです
インダキーレのごとくって
インダキーレっていうのは
この昔の建築の場合は
まずしっかりした柱を作るんです
ものすごい頑丈な柱を作って
その柱につけて  2階建物
3階建物とか もう 3階
4階ぐらいはありましたからね
昔も建物を作るんです
だから建物の命はあの柱にかかってます
だからそれインダキーレと言うんです
だから普通パーリ語ではインダキーラということは
このものすごいしっかりしている
全く動揺しないという意味に使う例えになっています
で 現代的になかなか 現代はいっぱい柱を作ってますからね
ビルの場合は 1本の柱では柱を作って
それに建物をつけるということはね
しないし 今は大きいんだからね
柱はたくさん必要なんですけど
現代のビルの場合でも頑丈なの柱ですよ
今のこの建物を見ても
この柱とかね ものすごい頑丈でしょうに
でっかくて 邪魔ですけどね
ホールの中で しょうがないんですよ
しかし 壁なんかは全然力入ってないんです
もうカーテンと同じなんです
この壁は もう蹴っ飛ばして落とすこともできます
だから建物はびくともしないんです
それでまあ橋を作る場合はね
橋の場合はもう柱が命なんですね
柱 柱作ってつなげておくんです
そのように この昔はね
一本の柱を作るんで 建物を作る
それインダ黄色というんです
このインダ黄色のごとく
インダ黄色は柱が四方八方からどんな風が吹いてきたってもびくともしないんだよと
チャトゥッビワーテービアサンパカンピオ
タトゥーパマンスップリサンワダミ
善人というサップリシャっていうのは良い人
善人 理性の悪い人 いわゆる仏道の悟りに達した人
偉大なる人を指しますけど
仏道を経験している人をそんなようなものであると
柱のようなものであると
よ有アリエサッチャーニアウィッチパセティ
ブッダに説かれたこの四つの真理を自分で知っているならば
この知ってるっていうことは頭で知ってることじゃないんです
やっぱりはっきり知ってることなんです
実践して だからブッダのブッダが世の中のありさまを真理として語っているんです
それはまず覚えて調べてみるんです
本当にそうなのかと そうなってくると
もう動揺しない しっかりした心が生まれます
だから このものすごい強い心を持たないと
意味がないっていうこと
はい では今日のお話に入ります
人生っていうのは楽しいか苦しいかっていうことでね
人生は楽しいでしょうか？あるいは人生は苦しいでしょうか？と
私たちが思う楽も苦も事実ではなく主観なのです
そこはまず大事なポイントで
我々は人生は楽しいですよ
苦しいですよと言っても
それは事実じゃないんです
自分の主観なんです すごい簡単なことです
例えば 東京みたいな都会は住みづらいと
厳しいという人を見て
東京以外はどこにも住みたくないんだよという人もいる
事実だったらありえないでしょうね
東京は住みづらいと言うならば
人間たるものには住みづらいでなければいけませんよ
そうじゃないんです 田舎の生活は不便で
本当にどうしようもないんだと泣いている人もいるし
やっぱり田舎の方が空気が綺麗で
水が綺麗で 野菜がいいものを食べられて
なんといいことかと言っている人もいるんですよ
だから人間いうその楽しみ
苦しみっていうのはあてにならない
北極は人間には生活しづらいんだよというと
どんな人間にも エスキモーの人々にも生活しづらいんですよ
いくら慣れていても それが事実です
しかし そんなことは全然精神的な問題にも何にもなりません
事実の場合は そういうことで
私にとって楽しみは他人にとっても必ず楽しみではありません
私に楽しいものは 他の人にとっては楽しみじゃありません
だから我々が言っている苦
苦楽は明らかに事実ではなく主観ということを覚えておきましょう
私が苦だと思うことは
他人が楽だと思うこともある
パチンコは楽しいと思っている人いるでしょうね
私から見ればよくも頭が怒らないんですね
あんなキャーキャーと
あの電子音で あれでリラックスするんだと
リラックスのところじゃない
私にしてみれば 通っただけでも気持ち悪くなるんだ
あの音に だからそういうことなんです
一人に楽しいんだけど
一人には苦しいということになります
それから基本的な苦ということを学んでみましょう
体の怪我などの痛みは誰にでも苦です
怪我をすると猫さんも痛いんですよ
我々も痛いんですよ それは主観じゃないんです
蹴られちゃうと私も痛いし
ワンちゃん蹴っちゃってもワンちゃんには痛いんです
そういう誰にでも共通している事実でなければダメです
だからそこは基本的な苦なんですね
それから病は誰にでも苦しいものなんです
病気になって この頃もう楽しくてたまらない
しょうがないということはありえないんです
そういうのは客観的な事実
心の悲しみ 憂いなども苦なんです
心が悲しくなったり 憂いになったりすることをすごい辛いんですよ
誰にしたっても 体の苦は他の生命に同じですね
しかし 心の苦は その生命の心の働きによって変わるでしょうと
そこで我々はもうちょっと勉強しなくちゃいけない
肉体の苦だったら 私も犬も同じです
お腹が空いた時の苦しみ
食べるものない時の苦しみ
肉体の同じです 病気になると
その苦しみもどちらでも同じです
犬にも熱が出たら もう人間に熱が出たら全く同じなんです
まあ違うところは早く治るんです
人間よりは瞬時に まあしかし
見てみると全く同じ しかし
心の苦しみはどうでしょうかと
それが例えば我々は悲しんだり悩んだりするほど
犬猫も悲しがったり悩んだりするのかと
あれは子供が死ぬ 動物の世界でよくあることで
確かに悲しむんですよ
何が起きたか分からなくなっちゃって
起こしてみようとする
おっぱいあげてやろうかなと思ったりもする
猿なんかはもう抱っこしたりとか
いろいろなことをやってます
何もしないとすごく悲しい
しかし 私たちみたいに悲しむのかと
人間は心はかなり働きますから
かなり悲しむんです 憂いもかなり強烈になるんです
動物はそれほど心を働かないんだから
量が少ない その差はあります
はい 次に行きます それから基本的な楽はあれの同じことを繰り返す
体の快楽は楽 苦 楽しみということになりますね
もう一度経験したくなる感覚ですね
我々 楽 楽しいというのは
もう一度あっても悪くないという感覚に楽というんです
心で感じる楽しみ 喜び
満足感などは心の楽しみです
だから体にも肉体にも楽しみがあります
心にも楽しみがあります
肉体の楽しみというのは
もうもう一度その経験したっても嫌じゃないということで
他定義ありません 心にも楽しみっていうものはあります
体の楽しみはおそらく他の生命にも同じでしょうと思う
まあ聞いてないんだから思うと書いたんです
まあこのじゃれたり遊んだりするっていうのは
動物の世界に至ってもありますから
まあ特にね 猫なんかはもう体の首の下とかね
もう嗅いであげるとえらい気分が良くて
牛も同じなんですね 牛のこの喉のこういうところを触ってあげると
もうガリガリとこうやって嗅いであげるとすごく喜ぶんです
だからそれはもう体の感覚で
しかし 心の楽しみには強弱
壮大っていうのは大小なんです
はあるんです 心の働き違いますからね
それぞれ人の ですから
そちらには強弱あります
弱い楽しみ 強い楽しみもあります
ほんのちょっとの楽しみ
すごい広く広げた楽しみとかいろいろあります
心の場合は はい これでそれ終わり
別なタイトルに入ります
今説明したのは何やというと
苦楽の本当の苦楽 まあ厳密にお釈迦様には従ってないんですけど
できるだけ一般論で それがもう誰にも逆らう
反対することできない
まあ本当の苦と楽なんです
だから私たちは毎日言ってる
楽しいんだ 幸せだとか
あんなのは主観で当てにならないんです
本当に楽しいと苦しいというならば
今説明した基本的な苦と楽なんです
それで考えてください
基本的な苦と楽だったら
そんな大げさな問題じゃないでしょう
それには誰も動揺しませんよ
ちょっと体が痛くなっただけで
治療すれば治るし で 問題はないんです
この未確認 未確認の苦と楽っていうこと
人間っていうのは一人一人
あれが楽しい これが楽しい
あれが苦しいと大雑把で言うんであって
はっきり私にとってこれこれが苦しい
これこれが楽しいということはもうはっきりしていないんです
認定していないんです
これ認定あると 私は英語の単語で考えたんですけど
アイデンティファイという
ベリファイという単語ではなくて
アイデンティファイということはしていないんです
実態はわからないが 楽を求める
苦を避けようとする ここから
おかしくなるんですよ
欲しい欲しいと思うんですけど
何が欲しいのかってまだよくわからないんだと
状態でしょ そうすると話にならんでしょうに
くれくれと言うんですけど
君 何が欲しいなのかと
いや あんまりよくわからないんだけど
ということになるんです
嫌だ 逃げたいと 避けたいと
何を嫌ですか？どちらから逃げたくなっているのかと
これははっきりしていないんです
このいろいろ問題 私のところに持ってくる場合は
私は真っ先にそちらにアタックするんです
この変な技術 何も使いません
具体的に言いなさいよと
問題は何でしょうかと
学校に行きたくないと子供が来たら
学校に行かなくちゃあかんぞと
そんなくだらん言葉に私は言いません
具体的に言いなさい なんで学校は嫌なのかと
ちゃんとリストでこれこれこれこれと
だからそれ言った子は OK なんです
具体的に言ったら必ず答えがあるんです
それで面白いことは その答え
その本人に何のことなく実行できるんです
まあよくわからんんだけど
言っちゃうと もう助けてあげることはできません
ただ なんとなく学校嫌ですよと
それだったらなんとなく間違って人間の会に来ただけの話の話です
過去生で言ったら地獄にまた戻った方がいいんです
ですから この我々人間の大きな問題っていうのは
この幸福になりたいんだけど
幸福を何やとアイデンティファイしていない
これこれが私に欲しいということはないんです
苦しみから逃げたいんだけど
自分どんな苦しみでしょうかと
はっきりしないんです
好楽は観念的なものなので
人の生き方もはっきりしないことになっている
だから現代人の生き方ははっきりしないんです
何やってるかさっぱり本人もわからない
ただ生きているだけ だから生きている
しっかり生きるために何かそういう目指す幸福のもはっきり設定していないし
もう避ける不幸もはっきり設定していないんです
楽だと得たものは 後々つまらない苦だとすることもあります
はっきりしてないんだから
あれが欲しいと思いますけど
自分になってからやっぱりつまらないんだと
あの人と一緒にならなかったら
もう生きる意味もないんだと言って結婚して
もう 2  3 年でもう別れている
まあ日本はすごいもう先進国だからね
ハワイとかメキシコとか
そういうところに行くんで
結婚式に行って成田で別れる
もう本当に世界一無意味たいんですよ
世界で誰もそんな馬鹿なことを
日本人以外は 聞いたことはないんです
でまあ一人一つのケースあります
インド人誰かさんの結婚式で
まあイギリス国籍なんですけど
インド人なんです まあ腰が抜けるほど金があるんです
それで有名なアメリカの女優さんかイギリスの女優さんか
誰かともう結婚しちゃったんです
そこでインドで それでもインドでやったんです
結婚式は どこかの宮殿
インドでありますからね
それを全部 1ヶ月間もう貸し切りで
各国からすごい人々を呼んだりして
それで来る人々にもう全部回りある高級ホテル
全部もう完璧に 全部もう貸し切り
でもう想像できない もうもうもう国際ニュースで流れたんだから
日本では流れていないんですけど
もう こんなことって世の中であり得るのかという驚くほどのことです
派手にやってもう想像できないぐらい金かけてかかって
で なんでそこすごいニュースになったのは
とこのオチがあるんです
お父さんがカンカン怒ってるんです
この人はな 参加しませんよと
なんか変なことやったでしょうね
だからインド人がインド人のしきたりに結婚するならば
まあインド人の伝統的なしきたりいろいろありますし
模様の人々はちゃんと挨拶をして
尊敬してやるもので なんか親に対してちょっと侮辱した態度を取ったと
あれほどのすごい結婚式で行きませんよ
私は行かなかったっていうことで
もうかなりのそこら辺はすごいハイライトしたニュースでしたけどね
だからまあ あの人みたいな愚か者は
ああいうふうな結婚式やります
やっぱりそれでも考えてみれば
自分の国でやりましたけどね
日本人がなんで 4 日間だけちょっと
アイドルまでもハワイに行って結婚するとか
まあだからここで私が言いたいのは
自分にとって幸福は何やということをはっきりしないんですよ
それでもしかすると タレントさんもハワイで結婚するんだから
私ももう一応 200 万ぐらいは手にもあるし
じゃあハワイに行って結婚
教会にはこれぐらいで
ホテル代これぐらいで
やっぱりまあ 10 万ぐらいはもう買い物もしたらもう残るんだぞと思って
結婚式やったりして それでそこでホテルで喧嘩して
成田で別れて お互い自分自分の家に帰ると
成田離婚というね 言葉までできたんだから
苦だと思っていた経験は
後の経験と比較してその時楽しかったという場合もあります
時々 なんで自分の人生苦しいのになんでこうなるのかと文句ばっかり言ってますけど
後で何年か経ったところで
ああ あの時楽しかったと
何をと よく言うでしょ
学校の時を思い出して楽しかったとか
その当時に聞いたら全く楽しいことも何でもないんですよ
それで私は何を言いたいかというと
人間いう苦と楽っていうのは何のこともないということなんです
ほとんどの人は楽しみの探求も苦悩退治もする余裕がなく
ただ流されて生きているだけなのです
それで その他大勢の人々はもう別に幸福は何よ？と聞いたっても知らないし
不幸って何よと聞いたっても知らないし
ただ生きてるんですよ
朝起きて なんとかなんとか
なんとかやって 夜寝て
また次の日朝起きて流されて生きてるだけ
余裕がないんです 人間にとって楽しみ
幸福なんぞやと考える余裕さえない
それはもうそなた 大勢の人々はそうやっているんです
それから世の中でよく言う
あの楽あれば苦あるという話
人生には山もあり谷もありと歌って落ち着くようにする人々には
楽の探検にも苦の退治にも余裕がないんです
あのサンバ見に行った
そなた 大勢 ハワイに行って結婚しようと思ってるのはあまり数少ないでしょ
だからなんか微かな乱視かもしれませんだけど
かすかに幸福のイメージがあるんですよ
ほとんどの人はそれも考えてないんです
教会で結婚した 教会がなくてもいいんだよ
ホテルでなんとか あの
あのベニヤ板で 作ってやりますから
こんな世界で仏教は語れませんだけどね
そんな程度の人生論で
教会で結婚すると言ったら
しっかりした教会に行かないんです
どんなビジネスホテルでもチャペルがあります
あの あの文句言うために
そこら辺でバイトで誰か雇ってるんですよね
おそらく 苦しい時も楽しい
悲しい 楽しい なんだかなんだかありますね
文章が それもあのなまりで言わなきゃ雰囲気がないんでしょ
だから面白いんじゃないんですか？日本に住んでる西洋人は
日本語にはなまりがないんです
本当は みんなしっかり日本語
私よりしっかり喋ってるんです
なぜかというと 日本人と一緒に生活しているんだから
なんで牧師さん あの人だけ訛るんですかね
それも結婚式だけなんです
なぜかというと あのわけもわからない変な訛りで
それも訛る方法も決まってます
日本のドラマに出てくる外国人がどのように喋るべきかを
このディレクターは教えますから
こういう風に訛って言いなさいよと
その訛りでなければダメなんです
いかにも まあ笑うんだったら
漫才になくたって そういうことを見たら結構笑えますよ
それで このそういう まあとにかく自分に自分にはこれが楽しみというイメージない人々がよく言うことは
人生には山があり 谷がありとかね
苦があれば楽にあるんだとか歌いながら生きているんです
だからいい加減ということなんです
結局はその人々も 苦楽の波も一定しないんです
この意味っていうのは
もう人間のいい加減な苦楽なんですけど
それは波なんですね この一定したしっかりした波じゃないんです
例えば山があったら谷があると言ったっても
実際の土地と同じなんです
実際の場合 山が急坂かもしれませんし
もうもう谷がもう上り坂はゆっくりかもしれません
いろいろ一定してないでしょ
あの数学で描くカーブみたいにきれいなものではありません
楽が長く 苦が短い場合も
その逆 苦は長く 楽は短い場合もあります
5 年間の苦でばっかしで
もう 3ヶ月間だけうまくいったと
また苦という風な場合もありますよ
あるいはかなり長く楽しく生きていて
突然何か不幸なことがあって
それは 2 3ヶ月間で解決しまったという場合もあります
だから 苦楽の波っていうのは一定しない
ほとんど楽だけの人生も
苦しみしかない人生もあります
また いろいろ人々を見ると
まあ楽しいことだけ ほとんど出来事は起こらない
人間もいる 何やっても不幸で全くうまくいかない人間もいる
この苦楽の波っていうのは
そういう風な波なんで
いろいろあります だから
自分の波はどういうものかと
自分自身で考えてみてください
自分にとって苦楽の波はどのようなものかと
苦の方が長いか 楽の方が長いかどちらかと
まずその波をちょっと書いてみてください
20年  30年の人生で考えてみれば
大体もうわかりますよ
歳は 60歳です 私はそんな波を描くまで長生きしていないんだよという必要はないんです
だいたいまあ 30年ぐらい生きていると
だいたいまあ 15年になってくると
その波が描けます 苦楽の波は
で そこを波描いただけで十分じゃないんです
それから苦楽の定義 本当に自分が苦
苦 グラフを書く場合はね
まあ苦と楽と まあ真ん中にね
ゼロのラインを引いて
苦はポジティブで ゼロの下マイナスの方に
じゃあ間違えた あの楽はポジティブで上の方で
苦はマイナスでゼロの下のラインで入れて
まあポイントポンッと入れて入れてみると
入れてグラフを一応書く
それからもう一度 本当にこの出来事
苦なのか楽なのかと この出来事は何なのかと
例えば不良の子供たちと一緒になって万引きしたんだと
その時見つかったんだと
それで学校にいろいろ言われて
親を呼ばれて 警察に連れて行かれて大変なことになったんだから
まああのマイナスどん底に本人は罰を入れるかもしれない
これは最悪でしたと 自分の人生では
書いてから後から考えてほしいんです
本当にあの事件は自分にとって苦でしたか？楽でしたかと
そういうひどい目に遭った瞬間で目が覚めて
本人がまともな人間になったならば
まともな人間にした原因でしょうに
だからどちらに入れるのかと
万引きしたところで見つかって良かったんではないかってことになるでしょうに
もし見つからなかったら
次からやって次にもやって
それから泥棒をすることにもなったりして
勉強もやめちゃって 学校もやめちゃったりして
わからないんですよ だから万引きしたんだけど
無事逃げられましたと
よかった 私はついてるんだと幸福の方にポイント入れてもわかりませんよ
だから まず我々は自分の人生のグラフを書いてみる
それからそのグラフはさらにどういうことかと考えて
またグラフを改良してみた方がいいです
そうするといくらか自分の波のグラフは出てきます
だいたいそれは業が働いてますから
苦楽はだいたいそのパターンでいくんです
それから次のテーマ 苦楽はどこにあるんですか？これ大事なことよ
楽しみはどこにあるのかということは
美味しいものに 美しいものに
食べ物に 財産に苦も楽もありません
金の束を見て こっちは幸せあるんだと
どうったことないんですよ
なんか美味しい 美しいものがある
なんて幸せでしょうかと
何のこともないんです
ものは生命と関わりを持つ時
ものを認識する時 苦か楽か生じるんです
だからもう鉄で作った何かオブジェがあります
ガラクタですけどね で
そこは楽しみでも何でもないんですよ
しかし そこと私というとの関係が成り立つんですよ
私はもう名古屋とかそういうところ
電車で終わったら 外を見るといろいろオブジェやオブジェが見えるんですね
見て あ 綺麗やと私は思ったら
そちらに楽しみが生まれているんです
なんてくだらんことをやっているのかとか思っちゃうと
私に苦しみが生まれているんです
なんで名古屋駅のこと思ったでっかい丸い石があって
すごいでっかい あれはあれ
回ってるんですよ どうやって回ってるかわからないんです
あの水の中に入れたような感じですっごく
ものすごくでっかいんですよ
回る回る どういうことかわからない
ああ いろんなことを考えるなとかね
とにかくあの水の力で回転するような感じです
しかし 石だからね 石か何か石のごとく作っているか
もうわかりません とにかく
だからどうったことないんですよ
それを見る我々はなんて不思議でしょうとかね
これ 周りに照明もいろいろ照明の遊びもありますから
まあ噴水もあったりして
まあそれを見て なんて綺麗でしょうかとかね
で思ったりすると そちらに楽しみがあるんですよ
だから認識なんですよ
で 私という生命がその品物と関わりを持たなくちゃいけないんです
例えば大金 銀行のあの銀行のあれ
銀行 金庫と言うんですか
でっかい部屋がありますね
そこを開けたところで
もういろんな大金 お金束出てるのは見えても
別に何のことのないでしょうし
自分のタンスを開けてちょっと開けてみたら
まあそれほど厚くはないんだけど
まあいくらか それ見ると
なんて私は幸せでしょうかと思ったりするし
だからこの認識の問題なんですよ
お金の束を見ると人は幸福を感じるならば
あのどこかでお金の扱って展示していくのがいいんですよ
みんな 100円ぐらい払って見て
幸福を感じて帰ればいいんです
だから物は幸福を持ってないということなんです
そのものを私はいかに認識するのかという
認識しないものの存在さえも知らないんですよ
例えば この宇宙の他の惑星やらいろんなところで
すごい高価ないろんなものあるかもしれませんよ
だって地球と同じだから
地球でも金とかあったりするでしょうね
向こうは環境厳しい 激しいんだから
むちゃくちゃ金があったりとかね
火山もむちゃくちゃ爆発したりするしね
だからダイヤも結構あるかもしれませんよ
でも我々はあるということさえも知らないんです
本当のところ なぜならば認識できない
例えば 我々は今 この部屋で
ここのここら辺で もう天国の天女
天女たちが住んでいるすごいお城があるからかもしれませんよ
見るだけでも楽しくてたまらなくなるぐらい
でもそれ認識できんで
そんなこと言ったっても
だからあることさえ我々知らない
認識できないもの 存在すらも知らない
だから苦苦楽に対しては自分の認識ということが大事なことなんです
ですから 苦楽は外に存在するものではなく
心の認識になるんです
これ結構勉強した方がいいんですよ
これじりじりと真理なんです
夏だから皆様にこの昼寝するために歌ってるわけじゃないんです
よく寝られるように と大事なことなんです
心の弱みがポイント 何かを認識すると心は動揺する
この心の動揺を楽として
また苦として判断する
人を楽しませる力は物にあるのではなく
心の弱みにあるんです
これが初めての言葉で覚えておいてください
私はいろいろ明言しますけど
全部みんな忘れちゃってますから
で これも一つの大事な言葉だと思います
人間の楽しさ 楽しませる力っていうのはものにないんです
心の弱みにあるんです
弱みに ウィークネスオブマインド
それが大事なんです 説明してあるかどうかわかりませんだけど
小さなことに対してでも
心は激しく動揺する 感動するならば
強い幸福を感じる だからどれくらい自分が感動タイプかってことなんです
ちょっと小さなもうつまらない花一つ見て
涙流しながら感動するならば
その人は結構幸せもんでしょ
だから心弱いっていうことなんです
ちょっとつまらない話を聞いただけでも
もう泣いたりとか感動したりとかね
そうやって簡単に感動する人は結構幸福を感じています
だから 俗世間で幸福になりたければ
もうむちゃくちゃ弱い心を持った方がいいんです
しかし 簡単に楽しみの波を起こすこと
心は同様につまらないことに対しても
激しく悩み 苦しみ 不幸も感じるんです
問題はそこにあるんですよ
ちょっとした花を見ただけで感激して涙が来る人が
ほんのちょっとのことにも悪いこと来たら同じこと動揺するんですよ
1,000円儲かったことで宝くじ当たったような感じで驚く人がちょっと1,000円ぐらいなくなったらどうなることでしょうかね
だからこの俗世間というのはいつでも何か隙があるんです
それが仏教で言いたいところなんです
俗世間で楽しむことは楽しんでくださいと
うかつに言えないんですよ
この西洋の宗教みたいに
もう大いに楽しみなさいよと
それは無知な人々には言いますけど
心理知らない人々に大いに楽しみなさいと言ったっても
心理学的に見ると心が弱くないと感動しないんですよ
例えば この柱に力いっぱいもう空気を口で吹いてみてください
動くのかと 動かないでしょ
強いんです じゃあ紙 1枚持ってきて
ふーっと口で吹いてみてください
パタパタと動くでしょうに
だから その波を立てるために弱みが必要なんです
だから 他の仏教以外の宗教では大いに喜んでくださいといい加減なことを言いますけど
大いに喜ぶ人は大いに苦しむことも同時に同じことです
俗世間の 俗世間の楽しみも苦しみも感じるためには
心が弱くなければ 依存するものでなければダメなのです
そういうことになるんです
心は依存するものでなければ
弱いものでなければ 俗世間でいう楽しみは感じないんです
マイホームを作ったそうとか
車買ったそうとか 新車買ったそうとか
もう コックリバーのワンちゃんも買いましたとか
楽しむことはできなくなります
これは手がいかないところにおいておきます
私は一応失敗 一回だけだからね
はい そこで仏教が言うポイントわかりますかね
俗世間とはなんで仏教はのってないのかと
幸福は悪い 正しくないと言っているわけじゃないんです
確かに心にすごい喜びの波が生まれて
感動はしていますけど
しかし心が弱いんだから
別なもの入っちゃうと同じ苦しみの波が生まれるんです
で 世の中は一切そういうことですよ
例えば温暖化 地球破壊する温暖化になったりとかね
そうならないクリーンなエネルギーといえば原発なんですけど
そうですかね 本当は結局は
二酸化炭素を出してません
何も出してないんです
原発を見ても 何も煙一つも出ていないんです
すごい美しくかっこよく作ってあって
どこかの原発のあるところに私は見学に行ったところで
その人々が言うのはね
この放射能についてみんないろいろ言うんですけど
肝心なこの場所は街路灯見えてあげますから
このここら辺調べてくださいと
それから外を行って 田んぼとか畑とか
そういうところに行って調べてくださいと
そちらの方が放射能の方が濃度が高いんだよと
自然の放射能 この中はもっと低いんだから安全だよと言っても事故を起こしましたけど
そのところは で だから原発はそうなんですけど
安く エネルギーを作ってますけど
逆に隙間ありますよ ちょっとした不注意で
もうあの儲けはもう何百倍も大きくなって赤字になる
世間というのはそういうこと
我々人生も同じなんです
ツケがなく 例えば日本人では日本ではよく言うでしょ
タダのものほど高いものはないんだよと
その通りなんです いいえ
これはタダですから どうぞという場合はちょっとやばいと
これは 思うのは それは世の中の本当の状況なんです
人間絡んでも絡まなくても同じことです
ただほど高いものはないという場合は
人間のからくりのことを言ってますけど
あれはもっと一般論に持って来れば真理になるんです
次 別なポイント 激しい波は辛いという
苦も楽も激しく感じるのは良いのですが
さらに問題が起こります
小さな子供はそうでしょ
子供はもう喜ぶときはむちゃ喜んじゃうんでしょうに
同時にちょっとしたことでものすごく泣くんですね
だから見てみると もうこの感情の激しいこと
いないいないばあと言っただけで笑っちゃう
笑う 笑えるでしょうかね
あんなことは で 子供にはそれはすごく面白くて
もう手足を叩きながら笑ってるんです
同時に ちょんまちょっとなことで
ものすごい涙を出しながら
もうキャーキャーと泣くんです
だから言ってるのは 我々にも子供みたいにちょっとしたことでも笑うことできればいいんですけど
問題がありますよ 問題は何でしょうかね
苦楽の波が心にとって辛いんです
この波自体がかなり心に辛いんですよ
楽しみの波であろうか
苦しみの波であろうか
波そのものが辛いんです
人の幸不幸にかかわらず
皆不安 恐怖感を味わう
落ち着き落ち着かず混乱状態でいるんです
とのわけで じゃあ今日説明する時間がないんだから
今説明します あの 心っていうのは何か情報をぶつからないと波にならないんですよ
水と同じ 水に風がぶつかってくれないと
水の中で波が生まれません
それでこのぶつかるでしょ
いくらなんでもぶつかって水が上がって波が来るんです
これが絶えずぶつかっちゃうとかなり厳しいんですよ
美しい波であっても 荒波であっても
絶えずぶつかると空気が
まあ例えばもう海の場合はこの浸食すると波が激しくて
そうすると荒波でも浸食する
滑らかな波でも浸食する
そういうわけで 我々の心に情報がバンバンぶつかるんですよ
これが絶えずぶつかるんです
ストップはないんです
目が開いてる場合は もう必ずしも刺激という現象がぶつかるんです
耳がある限りは どうにもならん
音というものはぶつかるんです
それで波が生まれるんです
この波自体が辛い たとえ幸福の波であっても
苦しみの波であっても
そうなってくると 楽しいんだけど
例えば音楽を聴いて楽しかったんだけど
どこかでなんか疲れてなんか残るんですよ
だからいつでも いくら楽しい人であっても不安があるんです
恐怖があるんです その不安
恐怖っていうのは この無意識なところで心が辛い経験をしているんだからな
何やってもダメじゃダメみたいの
ダメみたいだと 本を読んでも疲れるし
本を止めて寝ちゃっても疲れるんだと
じゃあ本は疲れるんだからテレビ見ようと思ったって
やっぱりダメや あれもとか
だから何やっても我々の人生でいつでも不安があるんです
ですから 幸福な心であっても
一貫して不安の波が流れるんです
この下で表面的には幸福ですよ
表面的に幸福なんですけど
下で心にもう一つ波があるんです
サブウェーがあるんです
このサブウェーは不安なんです
海と違います 海ではこの波があるのは上だけ
どんな見る？見ただけで怖くなる波がある海であっても
入ってみれば何のこともないんです
怖くも何でもないんです
自分の頭の上からドーンと波が来たら
別に気にする必要はないんです
なぜかというと これは上だけそうなって
次はまた静かになったり
しかし 海でも水が流れるんですよ
いろんな方向へ もし海の方に流れる流れがあって
この流れがゆっくりなんですけど
下で流れるんです それで上で波が来て
もう波は入っちゃったら怖くないんだぞとかね
波に当たってみちゃうと
その波が人を中に押しちゃいます
水の中に押したところで
下でサブウェーが海の中に流れるんだったら
もうどうしようもない
もう命は危ない さっともうかなり遠く持っていっちゃうんです
だからこのサブウェーというサブウェイではなくて
あの上のウェーブ 波はウェーブって英語で言いますからね
こう一つ上ウェーブがあるとあります
それはいろんな形なんですけど
下のウェーブが波が一定の波なんです
我々の空落の波と違います
一定の波 不安の波 偏見でごまかす
だったらどうしようかと
何か偏見でごまかしちゃえばいいんです
という前のスライドで何言いたかったというと
人間というのはいくら幸福自慢しても
心には不安があるんだよと
心には恐怖感があるんだよと
これがみんな生命は共通です
激しく楽しみも苦しみも感じないの
動物なんです なんとなく生きてる
何か餌を取って寝ている
興奮 興奮する楽しみもないし
落ち込むこともないんです
落ち着いているようでしょう
しかし どんな動物も不安を持っている
恐怖感は持っている そうすると動物を見ると
この裏にあるこのサブウェイは日本語で何て言えばいいんですかね
ウェーブは波ですけど
サブウェイだったら 深層まあ
サブは日本語で腹という言葉なんですけども
腹波ってあまり日本語で言わないんですね
深層波とか ん？えっ えっ
対流 大量 まあ心臓波というかね
まあそんな感じですけど
で 動物見るとその波がわかりますよ
どんな動物もはっきり見えるのは不安と恐怖感なんです
家で飼ってる動物でも結構怯えて不安で何があるのかと聞きたいんだけど
あんたには でもあるんです
大事に飼ってあげてるのに
そこでみんな動物に可愛がってほしいんだから
あれこれやとね もう美味しい食べ物を食べさせたり
それから 1万円の首輪をつけたりとかね
もう 1万5000円の服を着せたりするでしょ
で 動物に嫌われるんです
動物に愛されて欲しければ
あの波を 不安の波をなくしてあげてみてください
できません 一時的ですけどね
それ動物すごく喜び感じるんです
で あのゴーテにいる猫1匹以外
私と色々付き合っている動物たちは
私から餌がくれってほとんど言わないんです
他誰かから強引に餌を奪ってでも食べて
私のところに来て ものすごく遊んでいるんです
なぜかというと 私はいつまでも
どんな動物であっても
あの不安の波を その時だけでもなくなるようにいろいろ
手を打つんです 落ち着いたら本当にすごく
喜ぶ 一回太陽村に行った時はね
もう珍しい 窓が開けてあって
いきなり飛んできた鳥がもうわからなくなっちゃって
部屋の中に入り込んじゃったんです
で これ大変 外を出さなくちゃいけないし
暴れ回っちゃうし でま
とにかく私はもう 捕まったんで
鳥を捕まったらもう殺されたっていう感じで
強烈な恐怖感でキャッて鳴いたりして
それはすぐ外へ出そうと思ったんですけど
なかなか見たことがない鳥なんですよ
もう体もなんかすごい美しくて
くちばしもなんかすごいデザインでできてあって
それはすぐこの鳥をしっかり観察しなくちゃあかんと
逃がすより前に でもこれがもう殺されるぐらい恐怖感でいると
30秒でも捕まっているということは
あの鳥にすっごい苦しみを与えたことですよ
でも 30秒以内で私は鳥の恐怖感を全部伸ばしてあげたったんです
私の手の中でものすごい筋肉を硬直させて
握力ってものすごい硬かったんですけど
なんだかだらーんとしちゃったんです
それからほとんど 30秒ぐらい
あの ずっとある恐怖感はなくなったら
あ 怖くないかという感じです
ね こんなにしっかり自分をとってるんだから大丈夫と思っちゃうことになるんです
それから何のこともお腹見たりとかね
くちぶえこうやってあっちこっち首とかいろいろ見て
はい どうぞとそう出して出したんです
その時また不安戻って
ものすごい勢いで飛んで行ったんです
ですから この動物を観察するならば
このどんな生命でも感じる
この心臓の波が動物の場合は表にあるんです
なぜかと 我々みたいにもうディスコに行って楽しむとかないんです
動物はディスコに行かないんです
で 銀座の飲み屋さんにも行かないんです
ゴキブリ以外は ですから
もう人間感じる あの激しい楽しみと苦しみも両方もないんです
じゃあ偏見ごまかすというね
理想を捨てて 感情中心に物事を判断するんです
楽観主義か悲観主義に思考を傾けるんです
そこで我々は何するかというと
例えば仕事もする 給料もある
でもなんかもうあまりしっかりしないと
家族もいるんですけど
なんか無茶幸せかというとそうでもないし
これ以上幸せになれることになれるわけでもないしね
ということで それで不安の波が感じるんですよ
不安の波が感じると 何か変な偏見を作るんです
楽観主義になったりとか
あるいは悲観主義になったりとか
偏見を作ってギャーギャーとそればっかり言うんですよ
例えば絶対的な神様を信じると偏見になっちゃう
そうするとそれが楽観主義で
神様のところに行ったら助けてくれるんだと
生きている間はいろんな苦しみがあるんですね
理不尽なことは次から次へと起こる
それは全然気にしないことにする
なぜならば 自分が神様を信仰してるんだから大丈夫だという極限的な楽観主義になるんです
だから神がいるということもわからないし
これは全く偏見でしょうし
それ偏見でごまかす偏見があるんだからって
生きる苦しみ消えたわけじゃないんです
あるいは頑張るんだけど
大した成功はない いや
悲観主義になる 何でも批判したり
もうガチャガチャ言ったり
もうもう過激派になったり
それで苦しみをごまかすんですよ
例えば中東とかいっぱい過激派やらね
もういるでしょう テロリストとかね
微塵も人生の楽しみがないんですよ
若い子供なのに 全くもない
もう楽しみということは
ものすごい怒りで 激しい憎しみで
人類みんなもうもう破壊の目で見て
そこで生きていられるのかというと
見事に生きていられます
自爆テロ起こすまでには
食べ物がなくても何も言いません
だから爆弾を落とさなくちゃって思うだけ
それでこのだからって
その人々が一度も幸福になったのかとなってないんですよ
苦しみはそのままなんです
悲観主義者になったんだからといって
人生は幸福になるわけじゃないんです
楽観主義者になったんだからって
人生幸福になるわけでもないんです
現状は現状そのままですけど
納得いかないことは この深層波をごまかすんですよ
偏見で 人生の一つの側面だけを強調して見るので
その人の世界は単色で見えて
いわゆるそれはまあ 見えて落ち着いたような気分になる
落ち着いた これ偽の落ち着きなんです
だから世の中で宗教があって
哲学があって 政治論があって
いろいろポリシー対策があって
人間結構落ち着いてるんです
あれは偽の落ち着きなんです
落ち着いたんだからといって問題解決したわけじゃないんです
地震で何人か死んだところで悲しいんですけど
まあ阿弥陀様に召されたというんですか
だから大丈夫だと もうとっくに金の初の花に
もう阿弥陀様に迎えに来て天国にいるんだと
ごまかしですよ 例えば自分の子供 3 人いて
3 人も地震で死んじゃったと
母親にはそれからもう生きていられないんですよ
だって喜びなさいよと
阿弥陀様が迎えに来て
もう極楽浄土にいますからと
言うと あの悲しみは あの邪険にしがみついてなくしちゃうんです
なくしたんだけど 事実が現実が変わったこと変わってないんです
あの よくもういろんな文章とか冊子とかで聞かれる話なんですけど
この町 もう待ちに待って作った子供を立った子供一人なんですけど
お祈りやらいろんなことをやって
子供は生まれたんですけど
白血病とか それで必死になって治療するはもうもうなんとかですかね
骨髄移植するは あらゆる治療して
すごいもう保険も効かないよ
そういう病気の場合は
アメリカでは で まあ治療はあるんですけど
金持ちしかやれないという
だからまあそう金持ちの人々はそうやった記事結構読んでます
私も やっぱりそれでも死んじゃいますよ
それで神様の言葉でもう万事解決という
そういうことは我々人間決めることではございませんと
それは子供の運命はもう神様が決めることであって
ということで落ち着くと
だから偽の落ち着きなんですよ
仏教のことに詳しい方々はもうおそらく一人もいないでしょうと思いますけど
一応専門的に言うならば
この我々は空楽の問題から邪見というものを作るんです
邪見というもの その裏で起こるんです
必然的に そういうことのセクションは今説明しているところなんです
随分俗っぽく喋ってますけど
裏に厳密に仏教の心理学の
あります なんで邪見？証拠もないでしょうに
クリッションもできないのに考え方だけ捨てられません
なんでみんな我があると
そんなにもしがみついていますかね
波 苦しいんですよ 病気になるわ
死ぬわもう どうにもならんですよ
人生は そうするとすごい不安と恐怖感に襲われます
それで あ そんなことあったって楽しがるんだからってことで
もうチャラ だから必然的に邪見が生まれるんだっていうこと
楽と苦を感じるために邪見と無知が必要です
だから皆様 この人生を楽しみたければ
大いに邪見を作ってください
むちゃくちゃ この欲に溺れて生活してる人々いるでしょ
特に日本の宗教組織といえば
もう新興宗教組織なんかはもう金というと
どこかでこの宗教センターがありまして
なんか天国のように作ってますけど
くまらないんですけど
まあ場所は熱海なんですけどね
モア美術館でしたっけ
あまりにもバカバカらしくて
大した作品もないんですけど
まあその昔の宗教も そちらにいる人々はそこを見て感じて
なんてすごい世界だと感動するでしょうね
それで人生の苦しみを忘れると
私たちの開祖様がブッダの生まれ変わりだよと言ってあげたら
その信者さんたちが大いに喜んで落ち着くんです
ブッダの生まれ変わりも日本にいるでしょう
ブッダは生まれ変わらないんだけど
一人だったら我慢できますよ
結構いるんだからね だからそういう本人もその邪見で自分を誤魔化すんです
こんなことを言っていいのかという
あるでしょ 良心が痛いところは
だから何か邪見を作って
この痛い良心をちょっと舐めてあげるんです
とにかくこのスライドの結論は
俗世間で幸福であろうと苦しみであろうか
味わいたければ 我々に必要な条件 2つあります
無知と邪見 前の説明では心の弱み
無茶 弱い心が それから邪見があって無知がある
それだったらもう俗世間でウジ虫が汚いところで生まれて
クソの中で生まれて これこそ天国やと
思っているという話がありますよ
フンゴロガシは一杯大きなフンを作って
隣のフンゴロガムシ お前のフンの塊り私の方が大きいんだよと自慢するんだそうです
そのようにこの世の中で豊かさ自慢できます
この邪見と無知と心は弱いということがあれば
はい それからまた話飛びます
八正見法アッタルーカダンマという
ラブ愛想やそうて にんだーパサンサースカンティドゥッカムというやつですね
利益損 失明よ 誹謗賞賛
非難 楽しみ 苦しみ この 8つの現象で
心は楽しみと苦しみの波を作るんです
お釈迦様は全部簡単にまとめてあるんです
世の中で 8つの現象が起こるんです
この 8つの中で 4つで幸福の波 4
つで苦しみの波が生まれるんです
ブッダというのは この 8つだけを覚えておいてくださいと
ラブアラブ愛想やそう
にんだーパサンサースカンディドゥッカムという
4つ覚えて この 4つには負けませんよと
波は作りませんよと 頑張ってみてくださいと
それが幸福やと 智慧の幸福
波の苦しみをなくすために賢賢になるのですということで
それでこういう風にも波が起こると心がもうつらいんですよ
損して得して 次に損する
また得する やっていられないでしょうに
例えば ある時期はかなり世界で褒め
褒めてくれたりして 人気があったりして
それからクタクタ誹謗されたりすると
もうやっていられないでしょうに
心では 苦しいんですよ
その苦しみは邪見でなんとか
占ったりもするでしょ
調子が悪くなってくると
さっさと占い師のところに走っていって
占い師は今はちょっとすぐ良くなりますよというと
それでもう落ち着いてくれます
だから占いも邪見なんです
落ち着くためには もう何でも藁にでもすがるという
そんなにも落ち着きたいということは何でしょうかね
やっぱり苦しみの波があるんです
でなきゃ占い師のところに行く必要もないでしょうしね